நீங்கள் ஏன் ஏற்று உக்காந்துவிட்டீர்கள்? நான் திக்கேட் கலெட்டர் ராத்திரி பயின் ஒரு முழுக்கு வந்தால் 5 மணிக்கு கிளம்புகிறேன். நான் நெல்லூரில் அறைக்கிறேன், கூடூரில் அறைக்கிறேன், விட்ரகும்தால் அறைக்கிறேன் என்று எதிர்பார்த்தேன் என்று வாருகிறேன்.
ஏனென்றால் திக்கேட்கள் செல்லாது. நான் எதிர்பார்த்தேன் என்று தெரியாது. பிறகு நீங்கள் ஏன் ஏற்று உக்காந்தீர்கள்? நான் திக்கேட் கலெட்டர் ராத்திரி பயின் ஒரு முழுக்கு வந்தால் 5 மணிக்கு கிளம்புகிறேன்.
பிறகு நான் கேட்டேன் எனக்கு நான் பணங்கு வைக்கிறேன் என்று பேர கோச்சு, ஏசி கோச்சுலுகூட ஏதாவது நீ பயின் போட்டு எனக்கு திக்கேட் போடவேண்டும் என்று.
சரி என்று சொல்லிவிட்டான், ஏசித் திரீட்டை எல்லாம் ஒரு நம்பம் சொல்லிவிட்டான். நான் பார்த்தேன் என்னிடம் கேஷா இல்லை.
10 ருப்பாக 20 ருப்பாக் கேட்டேன் என்று கூறினேன். இந்தன்னெட்டு வேலை செய்யில், வேலை செய்யில், வாங்கிலிருந்து எடுத்துப் போடவேண்டும் என்றால் நான் கூறினேன்.
நீ எனக்கு ஒரு 800 ருப்பா என்னுடைய நம்பரில் போடு, நான் வந்தேன் திக்கெட்கு கொடுக்கவேண்டும் என்று.
என்னுடைய நம்பரில் போட்டால் இண்டென்றெட்டு இல்லையே, நான் எப்படி எடுக்க முடியும்?
அது பயிற்றும் இல்லை, அந்த இடத்திற்கு இப்போது உட்கார்ந்தேன், தீசி வந்தார்,
நான் உங்கள் நம்பரைக் கொடுங்கேன், நான் நம்பரைப் பணம் போடச் சொல்கிறேன்,
அப்படியெல்லாம் நடக்காது, காஷ்த
அப்படியெல்லாம் நடக்காதே, காஷ்தான் கொடுக்கவேண்டும் இந்த சிஸ்டம்ல, என்னுடைய நம்பரில் போட முடியாதீர்கள்.
நான் அப்படியே சும்மா பேசினேன், மராக்கிகாரன், மராஷ்டாள் என்று தெரிந்தது, நான் மராக்கியில் பேசினேன்,
இது மாதிரி ஒரு புத்த விஷயம், அவனின் நம்பரில் பணம் போடச் சொல்கிறேன், நீ என்னுடைய நம்பர் தீசியின் தொடர்புகொள்ளுங்கள் என்று கூறினேன்,
தீசி நான் இறங்கிவிடுவேன், நீ வரவில்லை என்றால், நீ இறங்கிக் கீழை போடும்போது உன்னுடைய பணத்தை நில்வேக்கு நீ கொடுத்துவிடு,
நீ உன்னுடைய கையிலிருந்து கேஷ் கொடுத்திருக்கிறாய் இல்லையா?
அவன் ஏற்றுக்கொள்ளவில்லை.
நான் பணத்தைப் போடச் சொன்னேன், அவனுடைய நம்பருக்குப் பணம் வந்துவிட்டது.
நான் 100 ருவா, நினைக்கிறேன்.
100 ருவா, 500 ருவா கொடுக்கும், 400 ருவா கொடுக்கும்.
சேர்த்தின் கேஷ் இருந்தால் அவனுடைய குடுத்திருக்கிறான், நான் அந்த தீசிட்டைக் கொடுத்துவிடுகிறேன் என்று.
அவன் போட்ட பணத்தை அவனுடைய கேஷ் வைத்திருக்கிறான், கொடுத்துவிட்டான்.
அந்த மாதிரி ஒரு, இப்பொழுது நுக்கு கட்டுரல் இருக்கிறது என்று நினைக்கிறது.
கட்டுரல் இருக்கிறது. கிட்டு வாகவேண்டும், கட்டுரல் போகவேண்டும், விதாஸ் அக்ஷன் கரமான். ஆனால் எங்கே தடப்பட்டு போவோம்? யார் இதைக் கண்டுகிறார்?